bien je vous propose
sans plus tarder de commencer
mes chers collègues
le programme de notre mission
d'information et dédiée cette semaine au
représentants des associations d'élus
nous commençons cette séquence décisive
de nos travaux par l'échelon
départemental je remercie l'assemblée
des départements de France de participer
à cette audition et souhaite la
bienvenue au Sénat successivement à
Madame Marie-Pierre mouton en
visioconférence président du département
de la Drôme présidente de la commission
éducation sport culture de l'Assemblée
des départements de France
accompagnés de Monsieur Stéphane Magnin
directeur des bâtiments du département
de la Drôme
à Madame Marie cyters vice-présidente du
département du Nord en charge de
l'éducation et des collèges en visio et
conférence également
à madame Cécile Dumoulin
vice-présidente au collège et au
numérique scolaire du département des
Yvelines
accompagnées de Monsieur Benoît garce
directeur général adjoint de la ville
patrimoine et construction en présentiel
pour le coup
à Madame Nathalie leandry vice-président
en charge de l'éducation et du numérique
éducatif du département des
Hauts-de-Seine en présentiel également
accompagné de Monsieur Paul Grignoux et
de Madame Sandrine le Morvan
à Eric Ferrer vice-président du
département de La Réunion
en visio
délégué au trafic aux travaux bâtiments
et la valorisation du patrimoine et à
Madame Marylène jouvia responsable des
relations avec le Parlement à
l'Assemblée des départements de France
en présentiel que nous que nous
connaissons bien de Marion
conseiller rééducation en présentiel et
de Monsieur Édouard Guillot conseiller
environnement de la DF en
visioconférence je voudrais saluer tout
particulièrement Monsieur Ferrer et le
remercier d'être auprès de Nous cet
après-midi depuis
la Réunion notre mission d'information
tient en effet beaucoup à intégrer les
problématiques ultramarines à son champ
de réflexion outre la participation de
Monsieur Ferrer à notre table ronde nous
entendrons prochainement le directeur du
Centre d'innovation et de recherche du
bâti tropical et la directrice du
conseil d'architecture d'urbanisme et
d'environnement de la réunion nous
aurons également des auditions avec des
recteurs d'académie ultramarines Mayotte
et Guadeloupe j'indique à votre
attention Mesdames et Messieurs que
notre objectif et non seulement
d'évaluer les besoins de rénovation des
écoles collèges et lycées liés à la
transition écologique mais aussi
d'identifier les défis notamment les
juridiques et financiers de cette
rénovation pour les collectivités
territoriales et surtout
d'évaluer l'efficacité de
l'accompagnement des élus locaux
s'agissant plus particulièrement de
l'accès à l'information et à l'expertise
je rappelle également que cette audition
donnera lieu à un compte rendu écrit qui
sera annexé à notre rapport et que son
enregistrement vidéo sera accessible sur
le site du Sénat un questionnaire vous a
été adressé en amont de cette réunion
nous n'aurons vraisemblablement comme
souvent pas le temps d'épuiser cet
après-midi tous les sujets qu'il
comporte mais vous pourrez vous nous
adresser par la suite des éléments
écrits qui ont enrichiront notre
réflexion je vous serais reconnaissant
d'autres que vous êtes plus nombreux que
prévu lors de vos exposés de vous
limiter à un temps de parole de 10
minutes environ afin de permettre à
temps d'échange avec vous après vous
après vous interventions pardon avant de
vous donner la parole notre rapporteur
Nadège avait va vous poser une première
série de questions
madame la rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci à tous
d'avoir pris le temps de venir nous
rencontrer aujourd'hui sur un sujet qui
notre point de vue est vraiment concret
en fait pour pour vous et lui
départementaux
donc pour essayer d'être efficace et
courte pour pouvoir vous entendre au
maximum en fait je vais commencer de
suite à
vous poser quelques questions est-ce que
j'ai juste une question par rapport à la
visio est-ce que vous nous entendez bien
merci beaucoup merci
quels sont tout d'abord au regard des
enjeux écologiques énergétiques et
climatiques actuelles les principaux
besoins des collèges d'après vous en
matière de bâtie scolaire et les
opérations de réhabilitation les plus
urgentes et qu'elle est approximité des
travaux déjà effectués à ce jour dans ce
domaine la proportion des collèges
nécessitant une réhabilitation à la fois
pour se conformer aux règles fixées par
le décret tertiaire de 2019 mais
également pour faire baisser les
dépenses liées à l'énergie ou pour mieux
aborder les périodes de fortes chaleurs
et si vous avez une idée du coût de ces
opérations nous sommes également
preneurs
je ne sais pas qui démarre en premier
madame mouton
bonjour
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
chers collègues
quelques mots d'abord pour resituer le
contexte les lois de décentralisation
sont arrivées il y a 40 ans pour les
départements en matière de collège et à
l'époque nous avons récupéré des bâti
qui était très vétustes donc au-delà de
la transition écologique aujourd'hui que
nous abordons en particulier sur le
sujet il y a eu déjà une remise à niveau
de l'ensemble des collèges et d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes a fait
un bilan assez positif de l'engagement
des départements qui ont multiplié par 5
depuis
82 leur engagement dédié va l'engagement
dédié à la restructuration à la
rénovation à la construction en
entretien des collèges alors bien sûr on
est très attentif à nos collèges c'est
un des collégiens sont
grand public pour nous et on aborde
l'ensemble des restructurations voire
des constructions lorsqu'il y a une
dynamique démographique
dans le cadre de la transition
écologique bien entendu cette transition
écologique enfin elle nous fait elle
nous a fait réfléchir d'ailleurs sur un
référentiel collège et je pense que je
suis présidente de la Drôme mais nombre
de mes collègues dans le nombre de
départements ont réfléchit à cette
transition écologique et à la
fonctionnalité de leur établissement sur
la base de référentiel collège de demain
qu'on a co-construit en plus avec la
communauté éducative et je pense on
parle au collège mais quand on parle au
collège on parle aussi gymnase et quand
on parle collège on parle aussi internat
et et évidemment il y a des transitions
écologiques il y a les transitions
sociétales dire que nos jeunes n'ont pas
la même idée du confort que nous et bien
entendu il a fallu s'adapter dans nos
référentiels que ce soit collège
internat ou gymnase à tout cela et quand
on a cette grande vigilance sur
remerciements on pense fonctionnalités
espace modulable que ce soit en
rénovation ou en construction on pense
architecture et il faut aussi se
rappeler qu'il y a des collèges ruraux
ou même ou même d'ailleurs
urbain où il y a des périmètres aussi
qui sont induits par des bâtiments qui
sont classés donc on ne fait pas non
plus ce qu'on veut il y a aussi la
qualité des matériaux sur lequel
aujourd'hui on est très focalisé et on
recherche aussi des matériaux biosourcés
on prend appui aussi sur le bois par
exemple il y a aussi évidemment le volet
énergétique et quand on parle rénovation
on va en systématiquement relanpine par
exemple mais restructuration même
construction on pense chaudière à bois
on pense plan d'isolation ventilation
performance énergétique suivi des
consommations et tout ça c'est inscrit
dans nos plans de
de demain dans tout ce qui est
rénovation et on a systématiquement le
souci par exemple je viens de construire
un nouveau collège il est tapissé de
photovoltaïque sur 700 m² on a fait
régulièrement et depuis nombre d'années
on n'a pas attendu
on n'a pas attendu cette période là de
guerre d'Ukraine et de crise énergétique
pour réfléchir aux économies de
fonctionnement parce évidemment dans nos
départements comme dans toutes les
collectivités les dépenses de
fonctionnement sont sont vraiment à
l'ordre du jour et chaque jour dans la
gestion de nos collectivités pour vous
dire aussi que parce que ça fait vous en
avez fait état dans les différentes
questions c'est que
vous avez parlé et c'est vrai qu'on a
reçu l'année dernière un guide du bâti
scolaire qui avait été écrit par le
ministère moi je vous le dis très
simplement comme j'ai pu le dire
ministre de l'éducation nationale se
baptise scolaire il a été rédigé dans
les bureaux des ministères sans se
préoccuper de la réalité de terrain sans
se préoccuper de la co-construction sans
se préoccuper qu'il y a des territoires
ultramarins qui a des territoires ruraux
des territoires urbains on ne fait pas
les mêmes choses partout on n'utilise
pas les mêmes matériaux et voilà c'était
un peu dubitative d'autant que ça nous
met souvent en porte-à-faux aussi avec
la communauté éducative avec les
enseignants qui reçoivent ça de la
tutelle de leur ministère et qui disent
ah bah c'est écrit là vous devez nous
faire ci vous devez nous faire ça c'est
un peu compliqué surtout qu'on a
l'habitude dans les départements qui
nous échelons assez pertinents pour
pouvoir dialoguer et co-construire de
réfléchir l'ensemble de nos actions à
l'aune justement de la co-construction
et puis derrière tout cela bien sûr et
je pense qu'on en reparlera et la
question du financement voilà toutes les
collectivités aujourd'hui vous le savez
on a plus de marge de manœuvre plus de
d'autonomie financière pour mettre en
oeuvre tout cela et voilà elle est
départements sont plus ou moins
confortables sur sur leur budget
aujourd'hui malgré ceux on sait et vous
disiez combien ça vous coûter ben un
nouveau collège ça coûte presque 30
millions d'euros entre 25 et 30 millions
d'euros selon la capacité à recevoir et
que tout ça ça se co-construit sur un
penture annuel d'investissement bien sûr
avec des aides qui manquent un peu
certes il y a le fond vert mais quand il
par exemple il y a des appels à projets
il faut répondre avant même d'avoir
pensé le sujet en 15 jours donc soit
effectivement c'était à l'ordre du jour
de la collectivité en tant qu'en
capacité de répondre dans 15 jours un
appel à projet soit alors on sait que de
toute façon c'est financement nous ne
les aurons pas
la présidente qui suit alors moi dans
mon déroulé j'ai si elle veut bien
madame marie-systère se vice-présidente
du département du Nord mais qui est
également en visio
[Musique]
bonjour à tous madame présidente a
pratiquement tout dit et je pense que
pour le Nord alors un département un
petit peu hors norme autant dans sa
population dans son homme de collèges en
2002 collège
public
on parle aussi du bâti et qui est lié et
je vous rejoins tout ce qui est logement
de fonction nous c'est 882 logements de
fonction pour ces 200 de collège donc
vous imaginez que la question de la
transition écologique qui est au cœur de
nos préoccupations pour le département
du Nord alors c'est vrai qu'on a une on
a au travail sur sur le volet donc de la
réhabilitation de la rénovation de
l'entretien des bâtiments de la
reconstruction et puis on a une grosse
enveloppe qui s'appelle le GER un gros
Entretien rénovation là où on a accès
notre politique Nord durable et sur
lequel on va aller travailler sur quatre
items
spécifiques sur la réflexion des
étanchéités l'isolation des toitures
terrasses la remise à niveau du
déploiement des GTB sur la totalité du
parc des collèges on va travailler
également sur l'installation de panneaux
solaires et photovoltaïques en
autoconsommation quand cela est possible
et puis sur le remplacement des
éclairages des salles de classe en LED
donc ça c'est un c'est un gros chantier
qui fait voilà qui fait l'objet de
toutes nos attentions et aujourd'hui
systématiquement lorsqu'on parle de
d'entretien des collèges on a toujours
ce focus Nord durable qui qui a collé à
nos travaux on a aussi mis en oeuvre un
contrat de performance énergétique pour
quatre collèges dans dans la baignoire
pour permettre aussi de de faire des
économies
substantielles sur ces sur ses collèges
là on a une moyenne d'âge de nos
collèges je suis accompagnée de notre
directeur des bâtiments en moyenne d'âge
de 27 ans le plus vieux collage je crois
une centaine d'années le plus récent
enfin il y en a il y en a qui en train
de se construire et donc ça ne fait
parler de d'aussi à notre à notre sujet
c'est que à chaque fois qu'on fait une
nouvelle opération on labellit ses
opérations on est sur sur du HQE là on
est en train de reconstruire un collage
à Cambrai avec une
ossature bois enfin majoritairement en
bois avec un niveau d'évaluation qui est
important et voilà on va chercher de la
performance plus plus donc voilà tout
tout ça est obligatoire et nécessaire
pour pour faire fonctionner nos 200 de
collège vous vous demandiez à peu près
l'état des collages au regard des des
des enjeux donc on a une quarantaine de
collages encore vraiment
un réhabilité pour atteindre des des
performances énergétiques meilleures au
niveau vraiment de de tout ce qui est
plus technique je vais laisser monsieur
Berthou en parler parce que là on parle
le chiffre on parle pourcentage et
j'avoue que je maîtrise moi
je vais essayer de compléter beaucoup de
choses ont été dites donc on nous avons
200 collèges il faut considérer que à
peu près la moitié des collèges ont été
construits
une soixantaine ont fait l'objet de
réhabilitation lourde notamment de
rénovation des rénovation de
l'étanchéité et des menuiseries et de
l'étanchéité à l'air pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur
dans le cadre du décrétaire applicable
en 2030
il nous reste à peu près un effort de 5%
à gagner soit 7 millions de kilowatts
par rapport à la consommation annuelle
que nous avons
puisque c'est le fruit de de quasiment
30 ans d'activité de rénovation de
collège autour desquels donc on a
au 30 derniers collèges reconstruit on
fait l'objet d'une certification HQE par
l'organisme certiféa et c'est quelque
chose qui se poursuit sur l'ensemble du
patrimoine
je rejoins ce qui a été dit concernant
les opérations
de construction ou de réhabilitation se
fait forcément à l'issue d'un échange
avec les communautés éducatifs puisque
un collège c'est pas un objet
monolithique qui serait qui qui se
répète on n'est plus à l'air des modèles
et donc il y a forcément une adaptation
et du programme et du contenu
au cadre bâti à son environnement et à
son environnement urbain donc pour tout
un tas de raisons y compris les raisons
de périmètre classé mais aussi une
réponse précise à une demande
particulière des équipes éducatives ce
qui fait et accessoirement la rénovation
énergie on peut pas prendre la
rénovation énergétique comme étant un
sujet dissocié du reste on a toujours
systématiquement une adaptation
fonctionnelle
à joindre puisque les pratiques
d'éducation nationale évoluent et puis
après les les effectifs des collèges
aussi évoluent par eux-mêmes donc on a
toujours un minimum d'adaptation
fonctionnelle et accessoirement on a
aussi la mise aux normes adap qui
intervient puisque il y a un calendrier
qui court sur l'accessibilité des
collèges même si pratiquement 95% de nos
collèges sont équipés il y a toujours
des adaptations à faire ce qui fait
qu'une opération de rénovation de
collège on ne raisonne rarement
uniquement en rénovation thermique sauf
sur les les points dont tu as parlé
madame psychiatre à l'instant notamment
les rénovations de toiture parce qu'on a
appelé le plan mur en durable qui est
plutôt une orientation technique que
d'orientation
générale par collège si on raisonne sur
un collège
qui est qui est donc qui est sur lequel
il y a des animaux importantes il faut
considérer qu'il y a à peu près un tiers
du budget qui correspond à
l'amélioration énergétique un bon un
gros tiers qui correspond aux
adaptations fonctionnelles diverses et
variées et le reste c'est des
adaptations techniques ou des ou des ou
de des choses qui sont liées à la misère
autant que ce qui fait que ce qui nous
pose une condition parle un peu de
financement et de et de et de de
budget à mettre en œuvre je rejoins ce
qui a été dit sur le fond vert le fond
vert il faut avoir fait toute une série
d'études préalables notamment les
diagnostic thermique préalablement ce
qui suppose pour les collectivités
locales un d'avoir les moyens techniques
et humains pour pouvoir mener ces études
préalables accessoirement aussi les
moyens financiers parce que ça
sous-entend un certain nombre de
diagnostics préalable sinon le dossier
n'est pas n'est pas
n'est pas éligible et surtout qu'on a on
a été on a répondu pratiquement dans un
délai qui était excessivement court donc
heureusement qu'on avait engagé déjà des
études et un diagnostic et un plan plus
annuel où on a identifié un certain
nombre de collèges sinon on n'aurait pas
été capable de de souscrire des
opérations qui sont éligibles
ça c'est un point qui est très important
ce qui est ce qui pose ce qui pose un
vrai problème pour des pour des petites
collectivités locales qui ont pas
forcément toujours les moyens et humains
et techniques pour pouvoir réaliser ces
diagnostics c'est vraiment une grosse
complexité mais madame la Présidente
juste avant vous vous l'avez dit et
c'est vrai que c'est c'est assez
compliqué pour nous et d'aller comme ça
en réaction sur sur des dispositifs qui
sont intéressants on va pas se le cacher
c'est important aussi qu'on puisse aller
en bénéficier mais on a vraiment cette
difficulté là de devoir agir très vite
et de devoir ne prendre en compte qu'une
réhabilitation thermique ou de
d'amélioration thermique en tout cas et
à côté de ça nous on a quand même
beaucoup de fonctionnalités à gérer en
même temps et c'est vrai que ça c'est
pas c'est pas pris en compte donc c'est
une difficulté
merci à tous deux oui allez-y
on vous le verrez dans les documents
qu'on vous transmettra la
le coût de l'énergie pour le département
du Nord et passer entre 2021 et 2023 de
11 millions à 35 millions
impressionnant
merci vous aurez la parole tout à
l'heure je poursuis le tour de table
j'invite maintenant maintenant de Me
Cécile Dumoulin à bien vouloir prendre
la parole merci merci monsieur le
Président Madame médecinatrice mesdames
et signatrices mes chers collègues donc
pour vous dire le département des
Yvelines c'est 115 collèges qui
représente
760 000 m². donc c'est 82% de notre
patrimoine bâti donc on comme nos
collègues nous n'avons pas attendu les
les
précédentes préconisations du décrétaire
pour pouvoir avoir des actions assez
fortes pour le
la sobriété énergétique notamment par
maintien en chauffage à 19 degrés à une
participation de concours cube de de
collège un efficacité énergétique qui
à part le renouvellement des nos
installations de chauffage qui a permis
un gain entre 10 et 20% et le recours
aux énergies renouvelables nous pouvons
se raccorder le maximum à des systèmes
de raccordement ou chaleur urbain ce qui
fait que entre 2017 et 2022 nous avons
déjà réduit de 17% notre consommation
consommation énergétique entre
2020 et 2021 nous avons réalisé un audit
énergétique sur l'ensemble de nos
collèges qui a identifier à peu près 79
collèges qui avait besoin d'une
rénovation thermique je rajoute à ça 15
collèges pour lequel on a un plan de
je pense que les Hauts-de-Seine c'est
pareil un plan de donc de collège avec
très très
comment dire
très peu énergivore avec des matériaux
bio sourcés c'est des collèges donc qui
sont assez ambitieux donc avec trois
cités scolaires pour un budget de 750
millions d'euros pour 15 collèges voilà
donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important nous avons aussi
souhaité avoir un recours aux énergies
renouvelables par l'équip de toiture
scolaire de toiture solaire par exemple
dans 65 à 70 collèges pour un montant de
10 millions d'euros a donc ça c'est un
investissement qui est important parce
que il permet d'avoir un retour sur
investissement rapide on il y a des
investissements qui sont
des investissements pour lequel on sait
que on a ce retour sur investissement
sera rapide celui-là l'est un deuxième
qui est sur les
l'amélioration des systèmes de chauffage
et de ventilation on a fait un CPE au
système sur 24 collèges donc pour un
montant de 35 millions d'euros et donc
ça on a un retour sur investissement qui
à peu près sur 20 ans donc c'est aussi
un investissement qui est important et
on a identifié aussi d'autres d'autres
collèges donc il en reste 50 qui doivent
avoir un plan de rénovation donc nous
comme les autres
départements on a aussi une approche qui
peut être globale parce que quand on a
des opérations assez lourdes on essaie
aussi traiter pas simplement le le
l'extérieur de l'isolation on travaille
aussi sur la restructuration parce qu'on
est extrêmement attentif au bien-être
des collégiens et d'ailleurs à côté du
référentiel sur l'écologie on a aussi un
référentiel fonctionnel pour qui se fait
qui s'applique dès lors qu'on
reconstruit donc pour nos 50 collèges
on en a identifié une dizaine et pour un
montant de 80 millions d'euros qui est
prévu
budgétaire pour la fin enfin la pour la
fin du mandat
si on devait faire l'intégralité de ses
collèges le on tendrait pour 400
millions d'euros donc vous voyez c'est
c'est des
investissements qui sont extrêmement
importants en parallèle on a développé
aussi un un plan de bien-être
dans les cours qui avec des
végétalisations des cours qui va s'adap
qui va concerner une cinquantaine de
collèges pour un montant de 80 millions
d'euros donc c'est à la fois aussi
évidemment des îles ou très chers
végétalisation mais aussi le bien-être
et ça se fait en concertation avec les
équipes éducatives
voilà donc c'est et donc je vous dis le
CP au système je vous l'ai pas dit ça
c'est ça permet de baisser de 30 % des
consommations énergétiques de nos 24
collèges concernés donc l'ensemble de
ces dispositifs qui ont été pour la
plupart voter qui sont en cours ça nous
permettra effectivement d'atteindre les
objectifs
qu'on nous fixe à l'objectif 2030 on a
une le département des Yvelines est un
département qui a des ressources
financières puisqu'on a un budget
d'investissement pour 2022 qui était
depuis 420 millions d'euros donc on a
un volant financier assez important
pour autant quand on voit le fond vert
je rejoins je rejoins mes collègues
c'est quand même assez difficile à
mobiliser et pour l'année
pour 2023 c'est 4 millions d'euros donc
vous voyez c'est aussi quelque chose qui
qui est pas non plus à la hauteur la
hauteur des enjeux et si je devais
formuler une proposition en fait pour
pouvoir
être quelque chose qui serait de nature
à faire avancer les
faciliter les mobilisations des
financements de l'État c'est qu'on
puisse avoir une une approche de
contractualisation parce que c'est vrai
que quelque chose qui se fait au projet
on a soit on l'a déjà voté donc les
financements sont actés soit on a la
réflexion n'est pas assez engagée donc
cette idée de contractualisation
avec un effet enfin plus réel
permettrait donc de donner un petit peu
de de solidité dans notre dans notre
politique ou dans les politiques plus
générales parce que comme je vous l'ai
dit nous on a pour les pour les années à
venir l'engagement financier mais vous
voyez bien qu'on traite pas
l'intégralité que le la marche est très
haute si on veut arriver à ces objectifs
qui sont fixés par par l'ensemble des
partenaires voilà
juste une précision Jean-Marie je remet
le micro pour les personnes ce que vous
appelez CPE système c'est de la
domotique c'est à la fois sur la
ventilation le chauffage et les
l'éclairage c'est du contrats de
performance énergétique voilà sur donc
ils insèrent donc on nous les titulaires
du marché assurent à la fois les
investissements et la maintenance
en fait on appelle ça système par
opposition un des CPE qui toucherait sur
le bâti par l'isolation là on est
vraiment sur des collèges sur lesquels
on n'a pas besoin d'intervenir sur
l'enveloppe mais on renouvelle
uniquement les systèmes donc chauffe
effectivement chauffage ventilation
électricité principalement
merci Madame Dumoulin à présent nous
allons dans les Hauts-de-Seine avec
Madame Nathalie leandry
[Musique]
sénatrices chers collègues
écoutez moi je vais un petit peu répéter
ce que vient de dire ma collègue Cécile
puisque le 78 et le 92 tout ce qui a été
programmé ça a été fait au niveau du
bâti par mon voisin monsieur Paul
cregnou qui est un des ga en charge des
bâtiments qui étaient sur le 78 donc
vous allez retrouver bien sûr beaucoup
de choses qui se font dans le 78 donc je
vais essayer d'être assez concise donc
au niveau de notre département donc
c'est 93 collèges ça représente les
trois quarts du bâti du département nous
avons bien sûr des projets de de bâti
neuf
nous en avons 10 pour une somme de 500
millions d'euros jusqu'en 2028 avec bien
sûr des gains attendus pouvant atteindre
de 54% et nous en moyenne les collèges
on y met 35 millions d'euros je parle
bien en moyenne avec un référentiel de
haute qualité environnementale alors il
y a les CPAS en effet tu en as parlé
donc sur 60 de collèges et là ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a initié cette
aventure depuis 2019 donc nous avons
vraiment eu un retour sur
investissement avec des baisses des
diminutions de consommation
considérables à partir de 3 ans on
atteigna 10% là on en est à 30% donc on
est on est très confiant pour ce qui est
préconisé pour pour
2000 2031
nous avons également donc 21 collèges
alors là qui sont plus énergivores nous
sommes en réflexion parce qu'il y a une
une somme de 150 millions qui est qui
est programmé mais ça concerne quand
même 7 8 millions d'euros par collège
donc il faut s'interroger quand même sur
ces cette façon de de démolir et
reconstruire mais plutôt peut-être ce
diriger vers le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables en tout cas ce qu'il faut
employer c'est réaliser qu'une fois les
investissements pour pouvoir atteindre
des performances directement sur 2040 et
non pas réinvestir tous les 10 ans donc
faire des investissements à plus long
terme
nous avons des projets de d'Ilo
repensés d'ici 2028 donc avec 34
collèges donc ce que les collégiens ont
appelé il ovaires c'est la
végétalisation des cours donc ça c'est
en étroite collaboration bien sûr avec
les équipes éducatives parce que je
crois qu'on a parlé de bien-être c'est
quand même le maître mot de ces
démarches là c'est c'est permettre à nos
élèves de vivre au mieux et les équiper
éducatives également ils sont très en
attente quand même de pouvoir vivre
correctement au quotidien dans ce dans
qui est dit vous l'avez dit madame la
présidente du conseil départemental de
la Drôme dans un état catastrophique
lorsque certaines collectivités ont
récupéré ce bâti donc
voilà et puis et puis et puis que
puis-je vous dire et puis il faut penser
bien sûr à tout ce qui est communication
et sensibilisation donc c'est vrai qu'on
nous mettons en place aussi beaucoup de
dispositifs
on a parlé des îles ovaires on peut
parler aussi du comportement parce que
rien que qu'une démarche comportementale
on peut arriver très facilement à des
baisses de consommation
on atteint facilement les 20% c'est ce
qu'on a fait dans certains collèges avec
justement ce projet cubes où on a
quelques collèges qui qui participent à
cette expérimentation et aussi la
formation de nos agents je crois que
c'est important de les former sur
comment gérer un bâtiment alors gérer
c'est à dire
comment comment gérer le chauffage
comment gérer la lumière pourquoi
comment la veille des vacances la veille
des la veille des week-ends des petits
gestes très simples qui sont vraiment
qui sont vraiment faisable par tous par
tous nos élèves par tous nos enseignants
il suffit simplement de l'initier et de
leur faire comprendre avec des gestes au
quotidien on puisse baisser vraiment la
consommation donc voilà en
vraiment en balayant rapidement ce que
nous avons pu faire peut-être monsieur
craigno puisque il a la connaissance des
deux départements 78 92 peut-être
veux-tu rajouter quelques éléments
oui peut-être pour pour compléter le
pour les Yvelines et je pense qu'on
règle mon collègue on s'en parle
beaucoup d'accord là où nous en sommes
en fait c'est se dire le il y a des
investissements qui sont utiles pour la
baisse des consommations c'est ce qu'on
a appelé les CPE système ça marche on
l'a fait d'autres départements ça a été
dit tout à l'heure le l'ont fait aussi
et on va dire pour à peu près trois
quarts du patrimoine c'est à dire celui
qui est le plus performant le plus
récent ou d'ailleurs pas forcément le
plus toujours plus récent parce que moi
j'ai un collège nous avons un collège
qui a un siècle il est très performant
auprès de dépend des périodes de
construction en tout cas pour le 3/4 du
patrimoine aller
changer les fenêtres mettre des de
l'éclairage LED ou faire des
interventions sur les systèmes de
ventilation de chauffage c'est peu
coûteux ça coûte moins d'un million
d'euros par collège et ça apporte en
trois quatre ans des économies
substantielles de l'ordre de 30%. si à
ça on ajoute les améliorations de
comportement d'usage voilà on peut aller
vers les 40%. par contre on a un quart
de nos patrimoine ou les investissements
là sont colossaux ça a été dit par
par les divines notamment mais c'est la
même chose dans les Hauts-de-Seine où là
vraiment on s'interroge aujourd'hui
après quelques années mettre en oeuvre
CCPE de savoir est-ce que c'est de
l'argent public vraiment investi à bon
escient quand on regarde des retours sur
investissement qui sont de l'ordre du
siècle à peu près
est-ce que et d'autant que vraiment ça
c'est quelque chose aujourd'hui qui nous
fait réfléchir c'est que là on parle
d'énergie mais on parle pas de carbone
c'est-à-dire aller faire des travaux sur
un quart de ses collèges ça veut dire
des investissements très importants soit
de la reconstruction soit de la
réputation lourde des impacts carbone
importants alors que peut-être mais on
l'a dit aussi un peu et c'est ce qu'on
est en train de lancer aller mettre ses
investissements sur la production
d'énergie renouvelable c'est peut-être
globalement on va dire pour dans
l'écosystème global peut-être un
investissement plus pertinent alors
aujourd'hui le système
favorise l'investissement et les travaux
mais il ne favorise pas la recherche de
production d'énergie renouvelables alors
il y a le photovoltaïque qui en
Île-de-France est une possibilité côté
pour à peu près un tiers de nos
patrimoine ça ça vaut à peu près sur un
tiers de patrimoine on peut en poser
mais il y a un potentiel géothermique
extrêmement important en Île-de-France
notamment dans l'ouest de parisien qui
aujourd'hui
on va dire déconnecter c'est réflexions
là donc nous voilà pour dire dans les
hautes en tout cas nous en sommes là
c'est à dire 150 millions 200 millions
d'investissements sur un quart de nos
collèges est-ce qu'il faudra pas mieux
mettre ces financements dans la
production d'énergie renouvelable locale
type géothermie
quitte à faire des travaux beaucoup plus
modestes sur ce patrimoine et le garder
en tout cas pour l'instant un peu
énergivore merci j'aurais bien aimé
avoir une précision sur qu'est-ce que le
projet cubes
c'est un projet
non comme ça vous aurez vous pourriez
c'est un projet national
alors je ne vous cache pas pourtant il
est très très intéressant et qui permet
justement parlait des comportements des
élèves pour savoir où ils en sont de
leur consommation puisque c'est bien
vraiment le des impliquer mais ils sont
très demandeurs alors je ne vous pardon
cube version scolaire version scolaire
à l'acronyme vous vouliez
et ces concours cube national version
scolaire avec le S voilà donc nous nous
avons apporté un soutien logistique
par exemple des thermomètres pour
mesurer la température du bâtiment de la
classe le matin quand on arrive le soir
quand on repart au retour des vacances
etc retour des week-ends et je ne vous
cache pas que là c'est un peu récent
donc on est allé chercher un petit peu
les collèges
nous en avons nous en avons eu peu cette
année mais je pense que ça va c'est très
parlant les résultats sont quand même
très très parlants et je pense que ça va
permettre quand même à d'autres collèges
de de
s'approprier ce dispositif un exemple
monsieur craignot vous avez le tableau
sous les yeux donc sur un collège
jusqu'à 48% c'est un peu théorique parce
qu'en fait on fait une simulation de
consommation énergétique du collège
et ensuite on mesure la consommation
réelle donc c'est pas non plus une
baisse réelle mais par rapport à ce
qu'un collège là moi j'ai des exemples
on est entre -35 et - 45%, mais c'est
entre du théorique et du réel
comportemental alors l'idée du concours
c'est pas tant d'ailleurs on va leur
absolu de obtenir un résultat chiffré
c'est en fait de classer les collèges
entre eux par rapport à un objectif
théorique et de voir où il se situe en
baisse c'est le pourcentage donc le
premier celui qui fait le plus de le
meilleur score
la réunion je suis interpellé par madame
la sénatrice qui
ne posez pas toutes vos questions
Marie-Pierre Monnier puis je salue
Marie-Pierre mouton
voilà ça vient nickel oui justement il y
a quatre il y a quatre piliers donc oui
au niveau du comportement mais moi je
voulais vous interroger plutôt sur le
volet collectivité
c'est des actions d'exploitation de
maintenant s'amélioration de pilotage
jusqu'au commissionnement complet des
écailles des équipements à maîtrise
d'ouvrages et savoir si des si vous
estimez que ce volet qui concerne les
collectivités et à la hauteur des enjeux
en matière de réduction et je poserai ma
question tout à l'heure la deuxième
rapidement en fait ce que nous avons
fait c'est que ce volet là nous l'avons
mis dans ce qu'on nous avons appelé
notre contrat de performance énergétique
système ou tous les installations sont
pilotées nous en avons renouvelé un
certain nombre celle qui nécessitaient
nous avons fait les travaux
d'amélioration et aujourd'hui donc on a
un pilotage et y compris d'ailleurs une
surveillance à distance des
consommations des températures et tout
un système qui nous fait remonter cette
donnée pour l'exploiter
mais peut-être qu'on peut ajouter aussi
c'est que dans le cadre des programmes
de gros entretiens renouvellement en
général quand on renouvelle les systèmes
de chauffage ou de ventilation pas
forcément dans le cadre d'un CPE parce
qu'on a aussi des programmes
d'investissement récurrents en dehors de
ce cadre contractuel on intègre la
question de de la GTB de la gestion
technique du bâtiment donc d'avoir ces
outils de pilotage en fait intégré à
chaque fois qu'on renouvelle ce genre de
d'équipement
très bien à présent je passe la parole à
Monsieur
Eric Ferrer vice-président du conseil
départemental de la Réunion
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je veux
souhaiter donc une bonne soirée et donc
nous concernant je dirais que
aujourd'hui donc à l'île de la Réunion
je suis à 70 collèges publics qui
composent le patrimoine scolaire de la
collectivité
départementales seuls trois collèges
utilisent le chauffage électrique comme
mode de chauffage puisque donc ces trois
collèges se situent dans ce qu'on
appelle la zone des Hauts de l'île ou
donc il était des températures
descendent des fois de manière assez
basse notamment pendant la période qu'on
a fait la période hivernale qui couvrait
d'avril au mois de septembre alors ces
établissements sont situés dans les
Hauts il y a le collège peut donner le
collège Alsace Cory situé sur la commune
de silaos si Laos étant le un des
cirques un des trois siècles de l'île de
la Réunion le collège Michel Debré situé
sur la commune tampon et à la Plaine des
cas le collège Gaston crochet qui lui se
situe aussi à la Plaine des Palmistes
alors le patrimoine départemental des
collèges constituent un parc immobilier
vieillissant en effet le plus vieil
établissement de Lille le collège
boisbon était construit en 1874 par les
pas du tout de tout ce qui est de normes
thermiques à l'époque et globalement sur
les 78 collèges existants 62 collèges
ont été construits avant en 1997 quatre
collèges ont été construits entre
1997 et 2000 et 12 collèges ont été
construits après les années 2000
au regard de ce constat il convient de
noter que la plupart des bâtiments
construit avant 1997 contiennent de
l'amiante les opérations de
réhabilitation sur ces bâtisses
scolaires ont donc un impact financier
important à loisir la plupart du temps
de travaux de désavantages conséquents
les fonds européens constituent une part
non négligeable de financement dans ces
travaux ou apparaît le volet de
rénovation thermique des infrastructures
à usage d'éducation et de formation
alors conscient de la nécessité de poids
suivre ses actions dans ce domaine le
Conseil départemental a voté un plan de
transition écologique et solidaire qui
vise à réduire l'impact carbone et
l'impact de la collectivité sur
l'environnement notamment en minimisant
l'installation de climatisation dans les
salles de classe et en privilégiant une
aération et une ventilation suffisante
par ailleurs au titre des relation menée
en faveur du développement durable et
plus précisément du développement des
énergies renouvelables notre
collectivité a lancé un appel à projet
ayant pour objectif la production
d'énergie électrique à partir d'unité
photovoltaïque positionné sur les
toitures des bâtiments publics
départementaux dont bien entendu les
collèges le soleil c'est quelque chose
qui ne mord pas la Réunion c'est une
sous-esthénie agit inépuisable et
durable ainsi à se joue à une trentaine
de collèges sur les 70 collèges 78
pardon collège public sont équipés de
panneaux photovolt voltaïques avec une
capacité de 11 GW
le système de ventilation des bâtiments
scolaires avec des ouvertures
transversantes présence de narcos ou
jalousie de part et d'autre des salles
de classe assure de manière globale un
bon renouvellement de l'air dans les
locaux d'enseignement par ailleurs et
depuis le renforcement réglementé à du
système de surveillance de la qualité de
Léa notamment dans ces établissements
il convient de noter que les évaluations
des moyens d'aération et des mesures de
la qualité de l'air ont été initiés sur
un site pilote à savoir le collège
Juliette Dodu si elle a commune de
Saint-Denis ces évaluations en lien avec
le rectorat et la TMO réunion seront
reproduites dans les autres collèges de
l'île dans cette attente et pour
permettre à surveillance régulièrement
des collèges les collèges pardon seront
dotés de 8 à 9 capteurs de CO2
alors quelques chiffres quand même
concernant les dépenses d'énergie alors
si on prend sur la période 2019 à
2021 en termes de consommation
énergétique des collèges en
kilowattheure on est passé en 2019 à
12730 12 millions
734240 kilowattheure et en 2021 on est
arrivé à 10 millions 997 774
la facture énergétique des collèges en
2019 on était à 2470 415 euros pour
arriver à 2 millions 270
625,24 ça ne descend pas autant puisque
donc il y a aussi là dedans et entendu
le prix du kilowatt-heure alors en ce
qui concerne la part de la facture
énergétique par rapport à l'ensemble de
la facture du patrimoine bâti 2019 on
était à 61 ,6 %
2021 à 59,33%
. alors il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas eu en fait d'un pack
significatif du coût de l'énergie dans
les trois collèges de l'île qui sont
aujourd'hui chauffés électriquement
il faut savoir aussi que les périodes de
chaleur de l'île de la Réunion même si
elles restent élevée n'atteignent pas
les situations caniculées qu'on connaît
en France métropolitaine toutefois avec
des effets de réchauffement climatique
les questions liées au chaleur
ressenties dans les salles de classe il
y a l'ensoleillement lors des activités
sportives deviennent plus en de plus en
plus
récurrentes la ventilation avec les
ouvertures transversantes couplées à la
présence de bras suédière assure pour le
moment le rafraîchissement des salles
les audites énergétiques liées au
dispositif éco-énéagique et à Sierre
vont être lancées fois tous les collèges
l'arrêt l'arrêté valeur absolue n'ayant
pas encore publié n'ayant pas encore été
pardon publié pour les DOM il nous est
difficile de savoir si c'est un collège
se rapproche déjà de cet objectif il
nous est donc difficile à se joindre de
quantifier le nom d'établissements qui
n'aurait pas besoin de réhabilitation
lourde mais au regard de notre
connaissance de notre patrimoine une
grande majorité des collèges devront
être rénovés d'un point de vue thermique
je suis accompagné ce soir de notre
directeur donc des de notre directeur
du bâtiment donc Monsieur Patrick
Pellegrini que je vais maintenant passer
la parole
merci bonsoir donc pour compléter ce
qu'a dit le vice-président de Monsieur
Ferrer pour faire des économies
d'énergie le département investi en
changeant des dents donc en faisant du
et du remping donc en mettant des lampes
pour beaucoup beaucoup moins et
consommatrices au niveau énergie ce qui
a permis effectivement de faire baisser
cette consommation et d'énergie
à partir de 2021
comme acier
Président nous avons un parc
vieillissant et aujourd'hui on a des
travaux assez lourds à faire sur nos
collèges alors qu'ils ne sont pas dans
le volet rénovation thermique mais
notamment au niveau étanchéité alors
même si effectivement quand on refait
l'étanchéité après on fait d'étanchéité
en fait et qui est isolante donc on
arrive un petit peu aux deux objectifs
mais on a quand même on a quand même des
investissements et conséquents à faire
aujourd'hui le département investit à
peu près 25 millions d'euros par an dans
les collèges
donc il y a de moins en moins de collège
neuf
le dernier collège neuf a été fait il y
a à peu près 4 ans
on a un collège qui est en projet qui se
fera d'ici 4-5 ans donc on est plutôt
dans d'autant de la réhabilitation donc
on est quand même sur des enveloppes
assez conséquentes
merci beaucoup pour la suite je vous
propose de procéder de la sorte madame
la rapporteur a encore quelques
questions qu'elle va synthétiser au
maximum pour que vous aussi vous
puissiez synthétiser vos réponses et
ensuite nous aurons attendez change
merci monsieur le Président on a parlé
financement j'aurais aimé avoir votre
avis sur trois choses qu'est-ce que vous
pensez du dispositif tiers financement
qui a donc été voté la semaine dernière
et je vois les sourires sur les visages
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la question
inspirée du rapport de la Cour des
comptes sur les collèges et la
décentralisation en fait donc qui est
qui dit qu'il serait opportun de
déforpétiser la dotation des
départementales d'équipements des
collèges afin de mettre son montant en
cohérence avec les réalités locales et
la troisième chose c'est dans le rapport
de marque de 2020 sur la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments scolaires ils
préconisait de stimuler la participation
active de la communauté éducative d'une
école à la mise en oeuvre d'un projet de
bonne gestion de l'énergie à travers des
comportements conscients et coopératifs
en faisant bénéficier la caisse des
écoles d'une subvention équivalente à
une fraction des éc onomies constatées
que pensez-vous de ces trois
possibilités
merci je propose
d'observer le même le même tour de table
que tout à l'heure j'invite donc la
présidente du département de la Drôme si
elles vont entendre
bien qu'elle pensait du Guide du
ministère
est-ce que est-ce que vous m'entendez
votre dernier votre dernière remarque
votre dernière question caisse des
écoles vous reportez sur les collèges
j'ai pas compris votre dernière
intervention en fait non je vous en prie
dans le rapport de marque de 2020 il
stipule enfin il préconise de stimuler
donc la participation active de la
communauté éducative et pour ce faire en
fait il mettrait une fraction des
économies constatées
dans la caisse des écoles voilà en
fonction de la fraction qui est qui est
d'économie en fait qui est constaté il y
aurait une il y aurait une sorte de
subvention qui irait à la caisse des
écoles en fonction de la de la part
qu'il se qui serait économisé
est-ce que c'est transposable au collège
pardon
département de la Drôme directeur des
bâtiments
pour le pire financement les balu en
totalité la loi en fait mais sur le qui
est passé mais sur effectivement les
aspects de
de faire porter l'investissement
effectivement par un tiers et sur lequel
on rembourserait en fait a priori sur
les économies en fait générer plusieurs
points peut-être le premier point en
fait c'est effectivement si c'est porté
par un tiers au niveau de
l'investissement quid du fond de
compensation de TVA en fait que si la
collectivité investissait elle-même
qu'elle récupèreait effectivement au
bout de quelques temps en fait enfin au
bout de gens en fait à peu près 15% et
puis après le terrain investissement
suggère aussi d'avoir une expertise
interne de la collectivité pour
effectivement bien suivre ce
type de dossier et donc d'éviter
effectivement certaines
complexifications peut-être en fait de
de cela néanmoins évidemment on voit
tout de suite l'intérêt par rapport à
l'aspect financement en fait que cela
peut apporter mais voilà ces deux points
d'attention me semble important pour
qu'effectivement les collectivités
derrière puis peut-être récupérer cette
espèce de fond de compensation TVA
qu'elle n'aurait pas forcément généré
elle-même puisque après la TVA serait
portée par le tiers mais quel serait à
devoir supporter sur le remboursement en
fait au niveau des économie voilà donc
là c'est un point important après vous
parliez de déforphétiser en fait
justement les dotations enfin demande la
Cour des comptes ça c'est pas bien
saisir parce que ça voulait dire par
rapport au territoire
en fait ce serait vraiment maître en
adéquation la dotation qui est versée en
cohérence avec le territoire nombre
d'élèves
en milieu rural en milieu
urbain pardon et ce serait vraiment
nombre des élèves d'élèves pardon
superficie également des bâtiments et ce
serait vraiment maître cette dotation en
corrélation par rapport à des données
fixées
évidemment des distorsions par rapport à
ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui puisque
effectivement un collègue peut être en
fonction de la démographie
derrière ou pas en fait justement et par
contre les frais fixes parfois des
bâtiments sont quand même fixes
effectivement pour chauffer en fait et
autres même si aujourd'hui on a de plus
en plus recours à la GTB en fait comme
on peut le dire en fait les autres
départements
et qui permet effectivement de réguler
chaque parcelle mais néanmoins en fait
cela pourrait effectivement pas examiné
selon les critères en fait qui serait
proposé en fait à ce niveau là
ensuite sur le dernier point sur la
stimulation de la communauté éducative
au travers d'un intéressement en fait à
l'économie c'est toujours effectivement
des solutions sur lesquelles on imagine
allait juste vous donner un exemple au
niveau du département de la Drôme
puisqu'on s'est posé la question voici
déjà presque une petite dizaine d'années
en fait justement
et on avez effectivement tenter la chose
simplement c'est très vite rendu compte
que par exemple sur un collège de la
Drôme en tout cas on était à l'époque
sur quelque chose d'environ 40 000 euros
en fait justement de de frais on va dire
de fonctionnement et donc faire 10%
indiquer que voilà on aurait 4000 €
entre guillemets à effectivement
répartir en fait éventuellement
et cela en fait
c'est une fois une année en fait je veux
dire c'est pas forcément pérenne en fait
justement puisque une fois qu'on a fait
l'économie on va essayer de la maintenir
par contre et c'est ce qui donne parfois
le plus de travail donc nous on avait
essayé plutôt de travailler sur tirer la
valorisation plutôt du et la
reconnaissance en fait du travail à la
fois déjà en technique de la communauté
éducative et dans ce petit cadre là on
avait fait une opération qu'on a appelé
cute donc les comités utilisateurs
techniques éducatifs où on avait
rassemblé à la fois le gestionnaire à la
fois le responsable technique et puis un
peu au-delà en fait justement pour
initier
transformer en fait justement à cette
aux économies d'énergie et en faisant
cela s'était touche un petit peu
regroupés les uns les autres en fait des
différents collèges et on avait trouvé
des solutions en fait avec eux pour par
exemple à l'arrivée des vacances
scolaires coupées tout ce qui n'était
pas
utile en fait justement dans le collège
en terme d'alimentation électrique et
tout et les résultats avaient été plutôt
performants on avait réussi à faire par
un plus de 10% d'économies d'énergie en
montant parfois jusqu'à 20% sur
effectivement l'exploitation après le
tout est d'arriver à maintenir en fait
le je dirais le l'éveil sur
effectivement ces économies d'énergie
mais il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui en fait
avec tout ce que l'on entend sur un
sobriété sur effectivement ces
aspects-là je pense qu'on peut
bénéficier d'une bonne dynamique
effectivement pour relancer en fait
justement ces formations et cette
stimulation donc sur l'intersement Oui
mais après effectivement c'est la
pérennité en fait de cette interaction
en fait qui peut nous poser des
questions en fait voilà
très bien merci Madame la vice-président
du département du Nord également en
visioconférence madame
oui merci je suis président par rapport
au dispositif du tiers financement alors
nous
le fait de faire entrer un acteur
supplémentaire dans dans le format ça
nous paraît être complexifié les choses
et peut-être rendre moins fluide et de
déposséder selon selon le cas la
collectivité de la maîtrise d'ouvrage on
a dans le cadre alors pas du des
collèges mais dans le cadre d'autres
votre réalisation ce genre de montage
et on se rend compte que c'est c'est pas
évident mais monsieur Berthoud va
peut-être
prendre des services départementaux donc
performance et donc on est vraiment là
dans le cas présent avoir un délégué la
maîtrise d'ouvrage et on se rend compte
que il y a une vraie difficulté et c'est
une gestion qui est qui est très
différente on a plutôt tendance à
considérer que à partir du moment où la
collectivité va être maîtrise d'ouvrage
d'expertise il y a pas vraiment grande
intérêt à
la transférer à un tiers on est aussi
nous solliciter par des gens du style
énergies sprogue qui travaille plutôt
dans le logement social et qui
parlent du principe que le modèle permet
d'industrialiser et c'est un
distribualisation permet de faire
baisser les coûts et d'améliorer la
rentabilité
au niveau des collèges en tout cas ceux
du département du Nord même les collèges
du béton qui ont été construits par
valentière on est toujours sur des
éléments qui sont différents et que je
doute vraiment très fortement qu'il
puisse y avoir une forme de rentabilité
et une
un traitement homogène qui puisse aller
dans ce sens là et imaginer que
l'économie d'énergie par elle-même
va financer la totalité de l'opération
encore une fois je rejoins je rappelle
ce que je disais tout à l'heure
l'économie d'énergie en tant que telle
ça représente enfin les travaux
d'économie représentent pour un collège
normalement de l'ordre de 25 à 30 % du
montant global de l'opération et dans ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure j'avais
effectivement oublié le
désamiantage qui est aussi toujours un
sujet qui vient complexifier les
opérations
voilà pour ce premier point pour le
déforfétisé les dotations c'est pareil
moi je n'ai pas vraiment compris la
question nous aujourd'hui on prend des
gens en compte le nom d'élèves et bien
sûr dans l'établissement le taux
d'occupation de l'établissement
de consommation les historiques de oui
de consommation d'énergie donc on va sur
trois ans il me semble
la dotation est toujours actualisée
en année voilà
et je voilà je sais pas
j'arrive question par rapport à ça en
sachant aussi que par rapport à la
question qui suivait sur le fait de
d'accompagner les équipes et de voir
comment on pouvait les
faire revenir
pareil au niveau des dotations nous
quand les collèges font des économies on
leur laisse la dotation donc en fait
elles ont toujours intérêt à faire des
économies parce qu'on vient pas
rechercher la part la part économisée en
quelque sorte et après on travaille
beaucoup avec les équipes pédagogiques
et les équipes des collèges pour avec
notre programme
éducatif du collégien où on a vraiment
des items qui sont spécialisés dans dans
dans tout ce qui est mis en oeuvre de
bonnes pratiques on a voté ici
dernièrement un nouvel appel à projet
sur sur mon collège durable donc là qui
va permettre au collège de lire à
nouveau
déposer des dossiers et être financé sur
du matériel et puis ce qu'on fait aussi
c'est qu'on a on a un nouveau contrat
de performance énergétique qui en fait
oblige nos
exploitants à faire des économies et qui
sont intéressés sur sur les économies
qui sont faites donc tout ça fait que
c'est vrai qu'au niveau du collège il y
a une mobilisation vraiment à tous les
niveaux à tous les niveaux alors je sais
pas si j'ai vraiment répondu
si si vous avez répondu en fait par un
autre système mais au final vous dites
que vous avez donc votre système à vous
c'est la dotation elle ne bouge pas peu
importe l'économie réalisée en fait vous
versez toujours la toujours la même
chose quoi
l'économie qu'elle a faite on le lui
laisse donc voilà et on voit que tu
réalises tous les ans les dotations donc
c'est vrai qu'on est au plus près bon
aujourd'hui
va se mentir on est plutôt à remettre au
pot j'imagine comme les collègues qui
sont autour de la table avec
l'augmentation des fluides avec
l'augmentation de beaucoup de choses on
parle que de du bâti aujourd'hui mais on
pourrait parler aussi de l'alimentation
enfin tout ça fait en sorte que
aujourd'hui on est plutôt toujours à
remettre un peu parce que malgré le fait
que les collèges sont vraiment engagés
et sont vraiment dans des économies
d'énergie aujourd'hui malgré leurs
économies d'énergie mais la hausse des
fluides on est quand même toujours enfin
il y a toujours ils sont toujours en
décalage et c'est souvent ce qui est
très frustrant pour les collèges et
c'est souvent ce qui nous est remonté
c'est que il y a énormément d'actions
qui sont mises en œuvre pour pour les
bonnes pratiques pour pour les économies
d'énergie etc et aujourd'hui malgré tout
ça et à cause de cette flambée des prix
ben voilà les factures augmentent
augmentent augmentent et on est plutôt
toujours à devoir quand même aider les
collèges une malgré tout sur ce sur ce
volet là un petit élément de contexte au
département du Nord ce sont les collèges
qui payent directement leur facture je
sais qu'il y a un certain nombre de
départements dans lesquels les pour
lesquels les départements recentrer la
le paiement des factures de fluides qui
du coup engendre un pilotage de
l'activité qui est pas la même
aujourd'hui c'est nous qui sous ce qui
va en contrat pour l'ensemble des
collèges mais c'est eux qui étaient
directement la facture d'où l'adaptation
de la de la de la dotation
merci Madame Dumoulin
donc sur la question de la dotation si
votre question c'est comment le
département distribue son ses dotations
de fonctionnement et non pas de l'État
c'est celle de du département nous avons
centralisé depuis déjà 10 ans de façon
progressive l'eau l'électricité les gaz
les contrats maintenant ce qui fait
qu'il ne reste plus grand chose en fait
à la charge des collèges et par exemple
quand on voit que nous aussi on a eu une
flambée de des coûts de l'énergie
puisque c'est passé de 8 millions 600
2022 à peu près on estime à 20 millions
2023 ce sera directement porté
exclusivement par le département et ce
sera pas supporté par les collèges donc
on a aussi une dotation qui en fonction
du nombre d'élèves et puis du mètre
carré et on est en réflexion justement
aujourd'hui pour la faire évoluer pour
qu'elle soit adaptée ou plus juste de la
réalité sur le sur le le fonctionnement
donc des écoles alors vous savez que les
écoles c'est pas comme les collèges
des collèges à sa propre autonomie son
propre budget c'est vrai que la caisse
des écoles peut être alimentée de
oui non mais oui mais en fait ce qui est
proposé pour la caisse des écoles et il
peut être je pense que c'est pas
forcément
facile pour les collèges nous on
travaille aussi par le concours cubes
donc on a 32 collèges qui ont participé
depuis une 2017 et donc il y a ça il y a
une un concours on a d'ailleurs
plusieurs collèges qui ont qui ont gagné
donc il y a ce travail qui est fait donc
on imagine pas forcément
après on a des appels à projets on a des
concours mais pas forcément une un
retour vous comprenez bien et sur le la
question qui est plus technique
Benoît qui va prendre la parole
donc oui sur la question du tir
financement donc effectivement nous on
avait eu dans le cadre de l'élaboration
du de la proposition de loi on a vu des
échanges avec avec l'administration avec
des parlementaires sur le l'intérêt du
dispositif qui était proposé
donc en fait il s'agit d'un l'idée
d'avoir un à titre expérimental une
dérogation à l'interdiction du paiement
différé dans les marchés globaux de
performance
en fait concrètement ça revient à
transférer la responsabilité du
financement à un groupement qui est en
charge de la mise en oeuvre d'un marché
global de performance c'est à dire qu'en
fait on confie un opérateur qui est
quand même normalement plutôt un
opérateur technique alors en général
c'est un groupement avec un maître
d'oeuvre un constructeur et un
mainteneur on confie à ce groupement la
responsabilité du financement de des
travaux d'efficacité énergétique et en
fait concrètement ça veut dire qu'on va
transférer la responsabilité du
financement au constructeur parce que
c'est lui qui a le plus gros bilan en
général
on a déjà un petit doute sur le fait que
les constructeurs seront intéressés à
portés sur leur bilan le financement de
ce genre d'opération
par ailleurs si ils ne le font pas sur
leur bilan et s'y mettent en place des
des structures de financement un peu
plus élaborées type financement de
projet on va se retrouver exactement
dans le même la même situation que les
marchés de partenariat
et on voit d'ailleurs que on est sur un
dispositif qui est similaire au marché
de partenariat alors il y a la question
de la maîtrise d'ouvrage en fait qui est
un peu spécifique c'est à dire que dans
un MGP le c'est l'autorité publique qui
est maître d'ouvrage dans un marché de
partenariat c'est le privé qui est
maître d'ouvrage mais une fine et une
fois qu'on transfère la responsabilité
de ce financement en fait quand on met
en œuvre des PPP il y a beaucoup des
spécificités du PPP qui sont liés à la
haute à cette question de responsabilité
de financement en fait parce que la
responsabilité du financement et les
toutes les contraintes liées au
financement et notamment toutes les
contraintes qui sont imposées par les
prêteurs
vont se retrouver dans la gestion du
contrat de manière très forte et bien
entendu le le la problématique qu'on
aura comme pour les marchés de
partenariat c'est que ce financement a
un coût et même si on arrive à mobiliser
des dettes à des à des dans des
conditions relativement favorables
notamment via la banque des territoires
qui peut se positionner même sur des
schémas avec du financement privé il y a
quand même la rentabilité des
actionnaires qui qui est incontournable
et qui renchérit de manière importante
le dispositif on voit d'ailleurs que les
conditions de recours à ce marché global
de performance expérimentale ont été
alignés sur les conditions de recours du
marché de partenariat avec évaluation
préalable étude de soutenabilité
budgétaire
donc nous on a on a du mal à voir en
quoi ce dispositif va être additionnel
par rapport à un marché de partenariat
en fait qui est déjà un outil qui existe
et qui n'a pas vraiment fait ses preuves
dans le domaine bâtimentaire d'autant
plus pour des travaux qui part nature là
sur la rénovation énergétique vont être
des travaux sur plusieurs sites de
réhabilitation en site occupé donc c'est
avec des des élèves dans le dans
l'établissement donc beaucoup de
problématiques opérationnelles pour la
mise en oeuvre de ces de ces contrats
qui font que on va dire même si on tente
l'expérience on risque quand même de se
retrouver dans des situations un petit
peu un petit peu compliquées en mise en
oeuvre opérationnelle pour aller
jusqu'au bout nous sur le sujet du
financement parce qu'effectivement la
question du financement privé ne doit
pas non plus
de se balader d'un revers de main
puisqu'on voit bien qu'on a du mal à
financer même dans les Yvelines on a du
mal à financer l'intégralité de notre
plan de rénovation énergétique et donc
du coup par définition ailleurs ça ça va
être ça va être encore plus compliqué
nous la réflexion qu'on avait tourné
plutôt autour de l'adaptation des
schémas d'économie mixtes notamment
une adaptation d'un des schémas de ces
mobs avec comme idée la possibilité de
sélectionner un investisseur financier
pour pouvoir participer à cette sémop et
de distinguer la sélection de cette
opérateur financier de la sélection de
l'opérateur technique qui est puisque
dans les dans la mise en oeuvre des
marchés de partenariat on a on a souvent
ce problème de devoir sélectionner tout
le monde en même temps et de confier un
groupement
on va dire d'opérateurs techniques des
la responsabilité de la mobilisation du
financement donc nous sur la le volet
financement privé c'est plutôt sur ce
type de de réflexion d'adaptation des
sémops qu'on avait orienté un peu le
notre réflexion
je rappelle que cette optionnel je tiens
je vous en prie merci monsieur le
Président oui par rapport à ce tiers
financement cette optionnel en effet
le département des Hauts-de-Seine
retient cette formule qui paye des sida
c'est-à-dire que demain si il y a un
tiers financeur
nous craignons de ne plus maîtriser de
décider quoi que ce soit donc c'est ce
qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui enfin ce
qui nous préoccupe pas tant que ça
puisque comme vous le disiez monsieur le
Président nous avons le choix de d'y
aller ou pas donc aujourd'hui je ne vous
dirais pas si on ira ou pas et ça vous
intéresse peut-être pas mais voilà ce
qui nous ce qui nous quand même ce qui
nous interroge nous voulons garder la
maîtrise de nos actions
en termes de financement sur ces grosses
opérations puisque ce sont quand même ça
reste quand même de très grosses
opérations
voilà donc je Tu compléteras peut-être
sur le tiers financement pour financer
pour finir sur ce sujet alors nous nous
ce dont nous parlons c'est d'un marché
global de performance donc vu les coûts
de développement que soient pour les
personnes publiques ou pour le les
entreprises et les candidats les
entreprises privées pour ce type de
contrat
moi j'ai en tête que on l'a on parle de
massification et de regroupement
d'opérations de montant assez conséquent
sur plusieurs ça a été dit d'ailleurs
par d'autres sur plusieurs sites
plusieurs collèges pour des montants de
l'ordre de plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros côté département
Maussane nous avons eu
nous avons tenté parce que ça c'est nous
avons arrêté au bout d'un moment de
faire un contrat de performance
énergétique sur nos 21 collèges à 150
millions et de massifiés il y avait pas
la problématique du financement parce
que on imaginait pouvoir en assurer le
financement sur plusieurs années en
trois quatre ans
la procédure a été déclarée sans suite
parce qu'en fait le marché
a jugé
le sujet trop complexe en termes de
maîtrise d'ouvrage
c'était l'aspect multicide c'est à dire
21 sites en même temps des travaux
réalisés pas exclusivement l'été mais
beaucoup sur les vacances scolaires en
site occupé et finalement nous n'avons
pas eu d'offres satisfaisantes enfin
plus précisément nous en avons eu deux
une qui était très dans l'estimation
mais très en dessous en termes de
performance attendue par rapport
notamment aux objectifs des locataires
et une deuxième qui était quasiment au
double de notre estimation donc le le
retour d'expérience de cette procédure
qu'on a arrêté et là on est en train de
réfléchir à une autre stratégie et
repartir autrement c'est que en fait
s'engager sur le il s'agissait de
contrat de longue durée en l'occurrence
de 10 à 15 ans s'engager aujourd'hui sur
une période à 10 à 15 ans
pour réaliser des travaux sur du
multicit
les entreprises n'ont pas assez de
retour d'expérience et de et elles ont
pas envie de prendre le risque tout
simplement et donc concrètement
aujourd'hui à ce stade côté département
des Hauts-de-Seine nous considérons que
la question n'est pas tant celle du
financement dans un marché global de
performance c'est ce que je viens de
dire bonneaugars d'ailleurs nous avons
l'expérience nous avons deux contrats de
partenariat enfin deux marchés de
partenariat de PPP si marchés de
performance
nous souhaitons avoir la maîtrise de ces
opérations de pouvoir ajuster en
fonction du savoir de l'expertise des
uns et des autres notre programme
d'investissement et pouvoir le dérouler
en fait en opportunité si on
contractualise la globalité sur 15 ans
on confie en fait aux partenaires privés
la responsabilité des moyens pour
atteindre certains objectifs que nous
aurons définis mais s'il ne l'atteint
pas que se passe-t-il et donc la
question en fait du financement à ce
stade dans ce qui nous concerne n'est
pas prépondérante et d'ailleurs enfin
nous en sommes plutôt à ce stade
à envisager pour les prochaines années
de lancer des opérations individuelles
pour justement pouvoir acquérir de
l'expertise
tester des choses peut-être un peu
différentes et pour peut-être dans un
deuxième temps peut-être massifié mais
ça nous paraît trop risqué pas que
financièrement de tout lancer en une
seule fois
je reprends la parole en ce qui concerne
les dotations de fonctionnement donc
comme dans le 78 nous n'avons repris
depuis 2017 nous avons repris tous les
contrats ça a commencé par les fluides
le chauffage les toits terrasse le SSI
les ascenseurs les portails voilà nous
avons tout repris déjà pour massifier et
aussi pour
faire des économies en termes d'achat et
pour alléger certains gestionnaires qui
avaient quand même du mal et certains
prestataires
voilà savaient qu'il s'adressait à un
collège non pas à plusieurs donc sans
donner à cœur joie au niveau des au
niveau des prestations et surtout des
prix donc nous avons tout repris
depuis oui depuis 2017 donc ça
n'intervient pas donc sur la pédagogie
la pédagogie la dotation reste entière
et il n'y a plus de problèmes de donc de
financement de ce côté-là
tour de table avec monsieur Éric Ferrer
plus chez vous nous donner de bonnes
informations s'agissant du tiers
financement
donc pour la rénovation de du bâtis
scolaire dans cette loi est récente
puisque
apparemment elle a été adopté sur
moi-même donc je crois que c'est le 9
mars donc temblé donc ça paraît pour
nous comme un bon dispositif donc il
faut qu'on rende réellement là-dedans
pour savoir si on peut l'utiliser
en tout cas tirer mon parti de ce que ça
doit nous apporte
je ne pourrais en dire plus pour le
moment mais sur la deuxième question qui
était relative justement à l'implication
à la participation notamment de notre
jeunesse je crois que ça s'il y avait
deux questions et donc je pourrais dire
que nous sommes conscients de
l'importance
de
d'éduquer donc des jeunes générations
aux enjeux de transition idéologies qui
est solidaire
le département
renforcera donc ses actions de
sensibilisation on peut décollégiens sur
plusieurs thématiques la thématique bien
sûr de sensibilisation aux économies
d'énergie dans le cas du challenge
départemental des sensibilisation
économie d'énergie en partenariat ici
avec le DF et science réunion mais pas
que ça mais aussi la connaissance et la
protection de la biodiversité je suis
moi-même le président du Parc national
de la Réunion qui classait patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO et vous savez que
c'est un enjeu majeur pour nous cette
protection de notre biodiversité
endémique et indigène et assure-toi
aller dans le sens de cette reconquête
de notre biodiversité qui depuis la
colonisation de l'île étant perte de
vitesse et
donc cette connaissance des protection
de la biodiversité grâce à une dotation
permettant collégiène de disposer au
sein des établissements d'un arboretum
des espèces indigènes et endémiques et
d'un Wi-Fi il faut savoir aussi que
département lancé
le plan d'un million d'arbres donc
monsieur l'ensemble des communes de
Lille et donc toutes les communes s'y
sont mises pour pouvoir justement
reconquérir cette biodiversité là mais
ça part aussi sur la réduction des
déchets issus de la restauration
scolaire et promotion au Bien manger
local avec des visites d'exploitation
agricoles accompagnées des distributions
de paniers de fruits aux élèves par
ailleurs le département
intériagit avec de nombreux enfants et
adolescents voire jeune adulte dans ses
propres structures et celles qu'il
finance dans ce cas de la prise en
compte du développement durable et
renforcer à travers des expérimentations
visant augmenter la part des produits
bio locaux ou issus de l'agriculture
raisonnée dans l'alimentation des
ateliers des activités de
sensibilisation métiers de la nature
aussi des actions sur les déchets voilà
donc on abordera pas ça seulement on
appliquera pas les jeunes seulement chez
la thématique de
de l'énergie mais aussi sur l'ensemble
des thématiques qui entrent bien entendu
dans le cadre du développement durable
très bien merci beaucoup à présent je
passe la peur à l'année à mes collègues
madame vous voulez bien prendre la
parole merci et Monsieur président
excuser j'ai une autre réunion donc je
ne pourrai pas écouter la réponse mais
je crois que c'est le représentants de
la Réunion qui ont parlé un petit peu
Damien moi j'aurais aimé savoir si il y
a encore aujourd'hui
des collèges dans l'état est préoccupant
pour la sécurité santé des personnels et
des élèves je pense à ceux qui sont un
petit peu pailleront et puis comme vous
l'avez soulevé amiante ou plomb
et puis une deuxième question sur le les
finances parce que vous les vous en avez
parlé les uns et les autres
particulièrement en ce qui concerne le
fond vert que ça correspondait pas à vos
attentes que les appels à projets
étaient étaient compliqués à monter et
surtout un peu de temps moi j'aimerais
savoir quel serait vos propositions sur
ce sujet là pour avoir plus facilement
accès à des ressources financières parce
que il faut bien y arriver à obtenir à
arriver à cet objectif de réduction de
consommation énergétique
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres collègues
souhaitant et s'exprimer à ce stade dans
concernant s'il vous plaît concernant
donc
l'amiante donc je vais quand même passer
la paroi de notre directeur donc du
bâtiment pour apporter quelques
précisions donc effectivement nous avons
beaucoup de collèges avec de l'amiante
alors pour répondre à votre question il
n'y a pas de problème de santé on n'est
pas sur de la banque libre en laissant
de l'amiante en fait et qui est dans des
matériaux donc ça veut dire que tant
qu'on y touche pas il n'y a pas de
danger et tant qu'on les perce pas donc
aujourd'hui on a fait un recensement
précisé d'amiante les collèges savent ce
qu'ils peuvent faire ou pas comme
travaux
et dès lors qu'on fait pas de travaux en
fait il y a strictement aucun danger
quand on fait des travaux par contre on
fait un plan en fait pour enlever cette
amiante
et sur vous voulez compléter la parce
que la question c'était surtout pour la
Réunion mais
c'était pas que pour la Réunion c'est
pour l'ensemble et les collèges payeront
enfin les établissements type Pailleron
j'avais posé la question à quelqu'un qui
est pas pu me répondre parce que c'était
du ministère je crois justement parce
qu'il expliquait que lui était pas
détendeur des établissements un juste
titre et que donc il pouvait pas donc
voilà
qui souhaite compléter
première chose sur l'amiante même
réponse que le collègue de la Réunion
assez peu et puis le programme
d'investissement enfin dans le
département des Hauts-de-Seine où on a
refait 35 32 collèges en 15 ans donc ça
nous a permis de réduire de façon très
très substantielle nombre de collèges
dans lequel il y a de l'amiante je dis
pas qu'il y en a plus mais en tout cas
les situations les plus
difficiles ont été traités et puis
concernant les paillerons nous n'avons
pas et d'ailleurs Nathalie Landry a dit
tout à l'heure nous avons repris aussi
les contrats de sécurité incendie de
système SSI pour cette raison là parce
qu'en fait dans les collèges il
n'avaient ils n'avaient plus ou pas plus
l'expertise pour piloter ses contrats ce
sont des objets de plus en plus
complexes donc ces choix qu'on a fait
les ascenseurs la même chose avec tous
les obligations réglementaires qui sont
apparues et qui sont renforcés ces
dernières années à juste titre
nous avions des défaillances majeures
dans la dans le suivi contractuel et
c'est pour ça qu'on a on a tout repris
je dis pas que il y a plus de risques
c'est pas la question mais
Jean-Paul prince oui tout à l'heure vous
avez dit Madame que vous aviez consommé
enfin payer
10 fois plus de coûts d'énergie dans
l'année
c'est pas ça de 2 millions à 20 millions
de 8 à 20 et partout ailleurs c'est à
peu près la même chose nous nous ça
passe de 15 à 36 entre 22 vous avez
doublé pratiquement enfin
alors même que notre énergie nous
lâchetons en Île-de-France via l'ucci
Perec et le sigef qui sont deux
syndicats
intercollectivités donc c'est si Perrex
150 collectivités et le tarif a augmenté
effectivement de je peux retrouver les
chiffres si vous voulez exacts parce que
je les ai là du coup du
voilà pour le gaz donc si Jeff qui est
un syndicat où il y a plus d'une
centaine de collectifs en Île-de-France
donc le mégawattheure est passé de 16
euros à 138 euros au 1er janvier
et pour l'électricité donc le si Perec
plus de 150 collectivités en
Île-de-France le mégawater est passé de
177 euros à 370 euros au premier janvier
sachant que si on vous appelles d'offres
collectif et la massification c'est
monsieur le sénateur si vous voulez
Marion conseillère éducation jeunesse
chez département de France nous pourrons
vous faire passer l'enquête qu'on a
qu'on a réalisé auprès des départements
on a des on a des variations enfin très
très importantes de 0 à plus de 450%
d'augmentation
en fonction de la nature de l'énergie si
on est sur des gaz alors là il y a des
augmentations à trois chiffres si on est
sur de l'électricité si on est sur de la
biomasse si on est sur voilà en fonction
des contrats effectivement vous le
disiez très justement Monsieur le
Directeur et puis en fonction des
territoires avec des différences
importantes au sein même de certains
départements d'un établissement à
l'autre en fonction notamment par
exemple donc on vous transmettra bien
évidemment les les éléments mais sachez
que c'est très variable et on a des
départements qui nous disent que pour
l'instant ils n'ont ils n'ont rien vu
entre guillemets sur les sur les
factures étant donné qu'ils étaient sur
des contrats plus réels mais que là il
tente vraiment le dos parce que bah il
les contrats arrivent à échéance et qui
vont devoir relancer des appels d'offres
voilà merci ça nous intéresse madame la
Présidente mouton vous laissez exprimer
me semble-t-il
simplement pour reprendre ce que disait
Marion Nahan enfin pour la drogue en
tous les cas et ça dépend un petit peu
le type de chauffage que l'on a et
d'énergie dans l'ensemble de nos
établissements effectivement ces 300%
pour les dépenses de gaz grosso modo et
en fonction des des contrats qu'on avait
à renouveler on est plutôt sur un
doublement du coût aujourd'hui dans
l'ensemble de nos établissements à
l'échelle de la Drôme je voulais aussi
rassurer en tout cas la sénatrice
dromoise qui a dû vous quitter
maintenant il n'y a pas
dans la Drôme voilà ça veut pas dire
qu'elle n'a pas ailleurs évidemment en
France et on a le souci aussi à chaque
fois qu'on a des rénovations plutôt que
encapsulé par exemple l'amiante c'est de
l'évacuer alors oui c'est un groupe mais
une fois qu'on l'a fait voilà c'est plus
à faire on a pu y revenir et quel que
soit les restructurations à venir on
sait qu'on sait débarrassé d'un problème
important voilà et pour revenir aussi
sur les financements et ce qui a soulevé
ensuite Marie-Pierre Monnier tout à
l'heure nous on trouverait plutôt bien
qu'il y ait un système type prime rénov
c'est à dire que à un moment donné il y
a des crédits qui sont qui sont portés
par l'État on était éligibles on n'est
pas éligible mais on sait que au moment
où on va les faire on pourra y répondre
dans les deux trois années qui viennent
mais en tout cas quelque chose qui soit
lisible pour les départements et qui
permettent de pouvoir y prétendre si
c'est la priorité de l'état une fois sur
je sais pas sur le rolemping une fois
sur sur autre chose mais en tout cas
d'avoir
une enveloppe et des notions des
critères de visibilité pour aller
postuler et candidater sur ses crédits
merci
j'insiste un peu lourdement mais il
apparaît que le coût d'énergie a
énormément diminué
donc est-ce que vous pensez que dans vos
contrats
ça va diminuer également est-ce que
c'est des contrats révisables ou pas oui
ils le sont sur les atouts une fois par
an mais effectivement une fois par an et
oui mais parce que maintenant vous en
avez pour toute l'année exactement mais
c'était parce que personne enfin je veux
le dire je peux pas parler au nom des
collectivités d'Île-de-France mais
jusqu'à présent le le gain économique de
d'acheter je parle de l'électricité par
exemple d'acheter aussi break il était
très important c'est-à-dire qu'on avait
un coût d'énergie extrêmement peu cher
inatteignable d'ailleurs en faisant
notre propre pelle d'offres mais avec
effectivement une clause de
d'actualisation annuelle au 1er janvier
enfin peut-être aussi là-dessus il y a
des il y a des collectivités qui ont du
renouveler des contrats de
d'approvisionnement en gaz au moment où
les tarifs étaient les plus élevés et
donc on voyait les évolutions de tarif
de marché qui ont pu aller jusqu'à x 10
en fait sur les tarifs du gaz là dans la
stratégie d'achat du CGF ils ont acheté
des volumes progressivement en cours
d'année pour pour pouvoir sécuriser un
tarif 2023 qui n'était pas non plus le
tarif parce que là on parle de fois 3
mais en fait si on regarde des tarifs de
marché on aurait pu être dans une
situation qui était encore plus
difficile en fait
bien s'il n'y a plus de questions moi il
me reste avant de vous remercier de
constater mais je ne l'avais pas appris
ce soir pas plus que mes collègues que
les départements n'ont pas entendu une
loi un contexte ou une conjoncture
conjoncture particulière pour s'engager
sur le chemin de la transition
écologique j'observe aussi avec
satisfaction qu'ils n'ont aucun souci
dans le domaine de l'ingénierie la
différence de ce que peuvent rencontrer
certaines communes de petites tailles et
je conclurai en rappelant néanmoins même
parce que je l'ai voté cette loi sur le
tiers financement que
d'ailleurs elle a été votée à une
large majorité que dans le Tiers
financement la maîtrise ouvrages reste à
la collectivité c'est juste une
dérogation au paiement différé et que ça
peut être bon c'est optionnel je l'ai
dit mais ça peut être une
les départements sont pas homogènes vous
le savez mieux que moi ça peut être pour
certains départements une manière de
faire
pertinente voilà merci encore pour votre
disponibilité et vos apports dans ce
débat très intéressant bonne soirée et
bon retour